حرب صامته على ايران ساحاتها الحواسيب
وجنودها قراصنه في الخفاء ومع اشتداد حده
الهجمات السيبرانيه ضعفت طهران موازنه
الامن السيبراني اثني عشر ضعفا خلال عشر
سنوات تقول السلطات انها تواجه الاف
الهجمات يوميا وتتحدث عن عمليات مماثله
استهدفت البنى التحتيه لشركه الاتصالات
زاد عددها عن ثمانيه الاف خلال عام واحد
فقط
يقف الكيان الصهيوني وامريكا وراء هذه
الهجمات مباشره او عبر عملاء اذ انهم
يسعون لتعريض امننا للخطر
من ابرز الهجمات اختراق الاف كاميرات
المراقبه وعشرات المنظومه الالكترونيه
التابعه لبلديه طهران
وفي ساعات الذروه هجوم استهدف البث
المباشر للتلفزيون الرسمي اما الهجوم
الاخطر فعطل خدمه الانترنت لنحو عشر دقائق
في كل ايران هجمات تستغل دور الانترنت
كشران حياه في اقتصاد ايران ويمكن تخيل
حجم الضرر في اي هجوم اذا علمنا ان اي
انقطاع في الانترنت يكلف خسائر بمليارات
الدولارات
ما يعني مزيدا من الاستياء في الشارع الذي
يشكل احد اهم اهداف هجمات تزامنت مع موجه
الاحتجاجات الاخيره في البلاد تؤكد طهران
قدرتها على مواجهه هجمات ترى انها تندرج
ضمن حرب شامله
فباتت التدريبات السيبرانيه جزءا من اي
مناورات تجريها المؤسسه العسكريه
اعتقد ان على ايران ان تتجه نحو استخدام
شبكه انترنت ومنصات تواصل ومعدات محليه كي
تتمكن من الحد من الاختراقات الالكترونيه
اضافه الى تدريب الموظفين الحكوميين على
تعزيز الامن الالكتروني
تؤكد ايران ان هذه الهجمات السيبرانيه لا
تمر من دون رد
وكالفعل في الحروب الالكترونيه
ياتي رد الفعل في الخفاء لا منتصره في
الحرب الافتراضيه بين ايران واعدائها ففي
مثل هذه المواجهات يحرص كل طرف على الحاق
خسائر جسيمه بالاخر وكسب النقاط الى حين
ساعه المعركه الحقيقيه عمر هواش الجزيره
طهران